we all get stressed whether it be from
work school or relationships but with
80% of adults in the u.s. reporting
daily stress
what's this chronic stress doing to all
of us what happens when you're stressed
every day within seconds of any stressor
your body goes into fight-or-flight mode
first your eyes and ears send
information to your amygdala the
emotional processing center of the brain
then from your amygdala the information
moves to your hypothalamus which
communicates with your autonomic nervous
system and adrenal glands these glands
then release a burst of the
neurotransmitter adrenaline
this causes the classic feeling of
stress increased heart rate increased
blood pressure and faster breathing the
adrenaline also triggers the release of
the stress hormone cortisol we always
hear about the danger of cortisol but
it's actually released to protect your
brain from the nerve damage associated
with trauma within 10 minutes of being
stressed behavioral changes likely take
place including increased aggressive
behavior around 30 minutes you may
become forgetful as stress can decrease
long-term memory and impair
concentration and after days of
consistent stress your sex drive will
likely decrease why from an evolutionary
perspective getting out there and
meeting would increase the odds of
predation so one theory is we may have
evolved to decrease our sex drive when
stressed to avoid potential threats but
after months of being stressed your
cognitive function will really start to
decline longitudinal studies of
employees in stressful work environments
show increased incidences of depression
and poor circulatory health a study on
rats showed that six months after being
chronically stressed the rats had
increased levels of anxiety and
decreased abilities to navigate a maze
this was due to changes in their
hippocampus all linked to increased
levels of cortisol this highlights that
although we know cortisol is meant to
protect your brain from trauma long-term
exposure to it can be detrimental with
all this in mind it's no surprise that
chronic stress has been linked to many
diseases such as obesity depression and
heart
and suppression of the immune system
with increased susceptibility to colds
sleep issues GI issues fertility issues
memory problems and even cancer
so trying to minimize your stress might
be a good idea but what can you even do
to lower your stress levels our latest
podcast goes into some tactics that you
can do to reduce your stress right now
based on studies and some of our own
personal experiences you can click on
the screen or use the link in the
description to check that out and
subscribe for more weekly science videos
every Thursday